wer hinter dem giftanschlag steht für
navalny ist dies völlig klar
bislang gibt es überhaupt keine
untersuchung in russland ich bin ja
nicht naiv ich glaube dass das ein
direkter befehl von putin war und
erwarten nicht dass es jemals eine echte
ermittlung geben wird ein anschlag mit
auftrag von putin schöner weil die
unzweifelhaft umso unglaublicher für ihn
dass ausgerechnet ein früherer
bundeskanzler auf der gehaltsliste des
russischen staates steht im bild
gespräch findet navalny überraschend
harte und klare worte über altkanzler
gerhard schröder und dessen freundschaft
zu vladimir putin den er einst einen
lupenreinen demokraten nannte jetzt ist
schröder in laufbursche putins der
mörder beschützt ich habe keinen zweifel
daran dass schröder verdeckte zahlungen
bekommt umso wichtiger dass es alexej
nawalny jetzt wieder gut geht und bei
mir jetzt philipp jakob aus unserer bild
politikredaktion und philipp du hast mit
kollegen dieses interview geführt mit
alexei navalny wir haben ausschnitte
gerade auch gehörte auch ausschnitte
bezogen auf herrn schröder gab es denn
da schon reaktionen aus der richtung von
gerhard schröder ja da kann man sagen
das thema ist heute wirklich viral
gegangen in deutschland sämtliche
zeitungen haben das aufgegriffen und
auch gerhard schröder hat sich dazu hat
dazu stellung bezogen auf der karriere
plattform linkedin hatte erklärt dass
die unterstellung von alex zähne
wahrnehmen das ist verdeckte zahlungen
gebe an gerhard schröder dass diese
unterstellung falsch sei und er
juristische schritte einleiten werde
das eine reaktion wir schauen uns
weitere reaktionen aus dem politischen
berlin einmal an
also ich fand die einlassung von gerhard
schröder zum fallen dabei auch schwierig
muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass das auch
eines altkanzlers nicht würdig war
ob der zahlungen fließen oder nicht dazu
möchte ich mich nicht äußern ich habe
dazu keine kenntnisse kann also auch
ehrlich gesagt so weit nicht glauben
aber trotzdem die rolle von gerhard
schröder schon zweifelhaft
navalny konnte dinge natürlich so sehen
wie er sie sehen möchte wir sind hier im
bundestag sehr intensiv mit dem anschlag
abwehren navalny befasst inwieweit das
man der ganzen politischen klasse den
ganzen parteiensystem einen gefallen tut
wenn man sich für russische großkonzerne
engagiert das ist ein thema über was wir
uns auch schon öfter geäußert haben ich
glaube immer dass es gut ist wenn
politiker sich auf das konzentrieren was
es gibt nämlich politik zu machen in der
aktiven phase genauso wie danach also
zunächst einmal freut mich dass eine
weile gesundheitlich wieder besser geht
aber diese äußerungen da befinden wir
uns jetzt schon auf stammtischniveau
ich finde auch herr wald nicht sollte da
seine worte wohl ab werk mir persönlich
fehlt der letzte schlüssige beweis der
nachweis wirklich gerichtsfeste nachweis
dass putin persönlich diesen angriff
hätte angeordnet ich meinen mittlerweile
ist ja sehr einfach man muss nur irgend
jemanden auf der welt vergiften mit
naughty dog um putin war es das ist
gerade sowie werden mörder eine
visitenkarte am tatort hinterlässt für
suppen das sage ich jetzt auch mal ganz
offen ist meine persönliche meinung
halte ich an putin nicht so gerd
schröder in dem zusammenhang möchte ich
mich einfach nicht mehr äußern
der vorfall ist bestürzend dass man sich
ganz klar ein verbrechen also gegen die
menschheit das ist nicht hinzunehmen
dass putin also hier mitverantwortlich
ist das halte ich für gegeben dann
entweder werden die nerven gehst du
nicht ausreichend geschützt oder sie
werden von dem eingesetzt one way or
other wie man so sagt also
ist das tatsächlich hier russland
anzulasten und von daher belastet das
natürlich für das verhältnis zwischen
deutschland und russland zu recht schwer
dass sich gerhard schröder der ja in
bezahlten diensten im russischen öl- und
gasgeschäft steht daran beteiligt an der
an der vertuschung und verwischung der
verantwortung die in russland für dieses
verbrechen liegt dass er sich daran
offen und öffentlich beteiligt hat
erfüllt in deutschland viele mit charme
dass er sich so verhält er ist jetzt ein
angestellter im russischen großen
unternehmen aber er ist auch der frühere
bundeskanzler und weil er das war
erfüllt sein verhalten jetzt in der spd
aber völlig jenseits von parteien viele
deutsche mit charme und es trifft auch
für mich zu viele wir haben einige
stimmen aus der deutschen politik
gehörte erkläre uns die sicht von der
wein was erwartet er was wünscht er sich
von der deutschen politik ja normal
wünscht sich vor allem eins klarheit
klarheit wie wir sie jetzt gehört haben
beispielsweise von norbert röttgen denn
ganz eindeutig sagt gerhard schröder ist
beteiligt an der vertuschung russischer
verbrechen
anders lässt es sich glaube ich nicht
sagen navalny will keine sanktionen die
sich gegen ganz russland richten die die
ganze russische wirtschaft eventuell
leben könnten erfordert personenbezogene
sanktionen gegen putins engsten kreis
alle korrupten beamten geschäftsleute
und oligarchen die hier im westen leben
können ihre kinder hier zur schule
schicken können hier ihr geld ausgeben
das sie dem russischen staat und der
russischen bevölkerung stellen das
forderte wahlen die von der
bundesregierung klare worte von navi in
einem spannenden interviews wirkte er
denn persönlich wie wirkte er als mensch
nach so einer vergiftung
gefahr nach nach einer vergiftung nach
lebensgefahr nach einem monat
krankenhaus ja er wirkte gut gelaunt
nicht weil ihnen die vergiftung
irgendwie belebt hat sondern er erholt
sich von der vergiftung und fühlt sich
glaube ich so hat er es uns gesagt
lebendig wie noch nie er hat ja auch vor
der vergiftung hunderte interviews
gemacht aber das war jetzt ein zweites
oder drittes erst und erscheint das
wirklich zu genießen wieder mit menschen
zu sprechen wieder raus zu können er war
ja fast einen ganzen monat lang im
krankenhaus davon mehrere wochen im koma
und er hat erzählt wie er selbst
simpelste dinge wieder zu genießen weiß
er war zum beispiel im regen im park
spazieren hat job vorbeilaufen sehen und
wollte mit joggen oder erweitern in
einem deutschen restaurant und hat ganz
klischeehaft wie er gesagt hat eisbein
bestellt und das wahnsinnig genossen
solche dinge machen ihm freude und das
war schön das zu sehen mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren